the Jeffrey Epstein sex-abuse Avesta
Gatien is intensifying in New Mexico
where authorities took him off the state
sex offender registry these exclusive
photos show Epstein's ranch in a remote
part of New Mexico where accusations
against him date back more than 20 years
mola Lange he got a first-hand look at
the property valued at seventeen million
dollars
this is Jeffrey Epstein sprawling New
Mexico home known as Zorro ranch the
compound sits high on a hill it's gated
entrance is shut and monitored by a
security camera the closest town is at
least 20 miles away and locals tell us
Epstein occasionally visited a few
restaurants but kept a low profile sex
abuse allegations against Epstein and
New Mexico date back to the mid-90s an
affidavit filed in April alleges Epstein
and his supposed ex-girlfriend ghilane
Maxwell told a 15 year old girl to take
off all of her clothes and then touched
her inappropriately
on a massage table at the ranch in 1996
and in a lawsuit filed Tuesday morning
an accuser claims Epstein coerced her to
engage in sex acts there between 2007
and 2010 Maxwell has not been charged
with a crime and has denied any
wrongdoing in the past after his 2008
florida conviction on child prostitution
charges Epstein was forced to register
as a sex offender
but in New Mexico he did not suffer the
same consequences as he did in other
states where he owned homes and faced
accusations
soon after the well-connected Epstein
registered as a sex offender here in New
Mexico state officials informed him that
he wasn't required to do so that's
despite having to register in Florida
and New York official documents from
2010 showed that just two days after
Epstein registered in New Mexico a legal
loophole allowed him to be taken off the
list
the reason the victim in his florida
case was not younger than 16 a condition
for registry in New Mexico but amid new
lawsuits criminal defense attorney Vinny
Vargas says a search of Epstein's Ranch
is imminent anything that this man has
touched is going to be examined and
scrutinized by the federal government
CBS News has obtained emails from 2013
which revealed that even after Epstein
was taken off
New Mexico sex offender registry he
personally informed law enforcement of
his trips to Zorro ranch and in recent
weeks New Mexico's Attorney General has
said he'll push for legislation that
would require anyone with a sex
trafficking conviction to register as a
sex offender in the state keeps getting
stranger and darker mola legi for us in
New Mexico mola thank you very much